كان في فقره وقفه مع الحدث خالد الغراب
لخالد اهلا بك ومساء الخير لماذا هذا
التعيين لننظر الى صوره الرجل الذي جاء هو
رئيس الاركان غالي الرجل سنرى صورته خلفي
هو له خبره طويله جدا من الناحيه النظريه
تخرج من كليه الدبابات عام 77 ومنذ ذلك
الحين هو في مجال العسكريه الا ان اصبح
رئيس الاركان هو همم الذي نراه بشعره على
اليمين همم وهو الذي اصبح الان هو قائد
العمليات همم قائد القوات الروسيه هذا هو
الرجل قائد القوات الروسيه همم في
اوكرانيا جاء ليحل محل سرجي» او ما كان
يطلق عليه الجزار سوريا همم لماذا غالبا
عندما يتم تغيير القياده هو عدم رضا من
القياده السياسيه عن القاده العسكريه لكن
همم ان كان حقيقه هو عدم رضا عن اداء
عسكري لاداره المعارك ااا لم نكن نرى هذا
الرجل حتى الان هو لم يتم ابعاده تماما عن
عن عن عن المشهد هو صحيح اذيح من منصب
قائد القوات لكنه بقي كان احد النواب
الثلاثه
اذا ابقى عليه وربما هذا الدليل على انه
لك نوع من الثقه في خبرته العسكريه الكثير
من الخبراء لنقل الخبراء الغربيين حتى
ناخذ ما يقولونه بكثير من الحذر لان من
الناحيه الروسيه طبعا لن تسمع الاشياء
الايجابيه عن القائد لكن من الناحيه
الغربيه التي تعتمد على بعض المصادر هناك
بعض التنحات هذا الرجل صحيح همم رسمه حتى
وان كان له خبرا نظريه عسكريه طويله جدا
لكن لا يشهد لهم الكفاءه على الاطلاق ربما
ما يميزه هو الاخلاص للرئيس بوتين همم هذه
الميزه الاساسيه بينما همم سلوبكين هذا
رجل كان مشهود له
القدره على تنظيم واداره المعارك في سوريا
قبل ان يصل الى اوكرانيا وعندما تولى
اداره الامور العسكريه في شهر اكتوبر
الماضي في اوكرانيا هو الذي سمح بصحب
القوات الروسيه همم اعاده تموضع لها وب
حديث عن القوات الروسيه تقيم خطوط دفاعيه
قويه استعدادا لمعركه الربيع وسمعنا
القياده الروسيه تتحدث بصراحه عن اخطاء
وعن همم طرق معالجه هذه الاخطاء على طريق
ان همم تصحح الامور وتواجه المعركه
المقبله اذا ما يبدو من الشاشه من المشهد
حاليا ان ما حدث ان الرئيس الروسي ابقى
على رجل له خبره عسكريه لكن وضعه تحت
صورتك من من له الاخلاص لفوتين وهذا معناه
عمليه نوتيد ربما هناك بعض الامور التي
تزعجه لا يريد التخلي عن خبره همم سلوفين
عمليه لكن لكنه يريد ان يعمل تحت
جلاسيماوف لضمان تنفيذ ما يريده بوتين
بدقه شديده ومن هنا نفهم انه ربما نوع من
احكام السيطر على القياده بدون ان يصل
الامر الى التشكيك في الاخلاص او وفاء او
قدرات قدرات العسكريه لهذا لكن نقول انه
نوع من ضبط الامور
ما حقيقه ماء يروج من انه نوع من التنازع
الداخلي خالده الغرابلي لدى العسكريين في
روسيا ربما طبعا يعني حتى تكون الامور
واضحه ويكون صادقين مع الناس هذه الامور
عندما تحدث مرتبطه بمعلومات نحن لا نملك
هذه المعلومات نحن نحاول ان نقرا بين
السطور لا توجد معلومات هذه امور عسكريه
ونحن في حاله حرب وروس من اكثر ال- ال-
الناس الذين يحافظون على اسرار بهذا الشكل
لكن ما يمكن ان ما تسرب بشكل واضح جدا ان
هناك نوع من ما بدا انه نوع من النزاع
الداخلي ليس بين العسكريين النظاميين
الروس ولكن بين العسكريين النظاميين وبين
الجنه التي اطلق اطلقت يدها الان في
اوكرانيا وسوليدار هي التي تحاول ان تعطل
انطباع بانها هي وحدها هذا الذي نراه
يديني بروجين هذا الرجل هو الذي اسس
فاكنارو وهو الذي يقود فاكنارو وهو الذي
ظهر في سوليدار يغيقوه انه هو وقوته الذين
يحررون او يحاولون سيطره على سوليدار وهذا
كانت نوع من الانتقاد بان الجيش الروسي
النظامي ليس هو من يقاتل في ضربه انما هو
صنعت منه انتقادات علنيه وحاده همم بشان
جنرالات الروس في القياده العسكريه وواضح
انه همم جماعه
همم
يحاول ان يظهر نفسه كما انه هو اليد
العليا التي تستطيع ان تحقق لبوتين ما لم
يتمكن ان يحقيقه الجيش الروسي واعتمادا
على ما يحققه على الارض ربما يامل في منصب
رسمي اكثر اهميه ومن هنا تبدو الامور قد
يكون هذا احد الاسباب التي ازعجت رجل مثل
ولد نوع من الحساسيه لانه همم س هو الذي
كان يقود العمليه العسكريه كلها في
اوكرانيا وعندما ياتي بروجين يتحدث الان
انه هو الذي يستطيع التقدم على الارض قد
يولد حساسيه بين الرجلين وبوتين يحتاج الى
رجلين تحقيق انتصار على الارض ومن هنا
ربما يكون السبب الحقيقه انه ارسل رسيفر
يحاول ان يضبط العلاقه بين رجلين لكن يريد
ان يبقي على رجلين في ساحه المعركه احدهم
همم معروف بشارته في القتال والاخر معروف
بتخطيطه على المدى البعيد واعداده للقوات
على الماده البعيد وهو يريد انجاز
والتحضير المستقبل كلها شكرا جزيلا لك يا
خالد معنا في فقره وقتها مع